you know who else doesn't agree with the
direction america is going right now
that people would be surprised with
a guy named barack obama is not happy
with the direction things are going
right now he himself was like listen man
you know
kind of temper it down a little bit with
the association even two names the other
day
sean penn very leftist type of guy
uh semi-socialist yes yeah fan of hugo
chavez yeah what i recall yeah
and conan o'brien you know it's more of
a common sense jokester but definitely
i think conan is a center game yeah well
but they both
they both called out the woke cancel
culture out there
look we talk about this all the time not
to get too political here sometimes
you need people on your team to
basically say look i don't like what
you're doing
rather than people on the other side
calling you out absolutely that's what's
happening in the democratic party right
here's what i would tell you this is the
other part
this is the other part this is the other
part that people are gonna have to
argue and it's gonna favor one guy i
hate to say this but it's going to favor
one guy
so just a few months ago when trump gave
the speech at sp cpac
and they were you know voter approval
people wanting him to run et cetera et
cetera he was at 50
okay just this last week when he ran i
think he was like he spoke to them i
think it was 76
yeah and second place was the santa's 21
right
so he went from 50 to 70 and desantis 21
which they're talking about him and
desantis president
vp type of thing to go out and do it now
we'll see if that's going to take place
or not
here's what i will tell you so take
trump's name out let's take trump's name
out okay
and you go look at his policies you look
at what his policies did
how many people on the left center and
right are starting to realize
yes he may have been a divisive guy yes
he may have been a guy that was pinning
everybody you know he was doing what he
was doing battling against the
mainstream media all the stuff that he
was doing
but his policies made a lot of sense he
called out tick tock
everybody disagreed now ashton kutcher
saying that
he he was handling the border very well
now we have issues at the border they
don't even want to touch it
we we were doing okay with getting the
vaccine to be expedited in nine months
on how quickly he got a vaccine
faulty said it will take 18 months at
the earliest to get it out
his sanctions against cuba that he put
on nine months ago
saying if cuba doesn't get it together
the entire world is going to be free we
have to make sure the entire world is
free
and we have to let go of those political
prisoners that cuba has what do you
think the
cuban people right now are protesting
here's the point
i think there's a part of the current
elections
the process that we have that i don't
agree with
and i don't know what it is here's
here's one of the things
we we vote more for personality than
policies today
if we took out the personality
mainstream media couldn't do what they
do let me explain
if all we said is we have three things
we're campaigning on
this is a this is b this is c take away
personalities it's purely policies
that we're campaigning on right who do
you bash what do you bash
who cares the policies don't grab
anybody by you know what policies don't
go out there and do
what sniffing somebody's uh hair with uh
what biden does right
if you just put it on policies how do
you trash the policies
you can't say a person you can't pin
them to you just have to say
that policy just kind of makes sense i
agree with that policy so there's
no more to rage emotionally against the
personality you
dislike because the media keeps talking
about this guy's a bad guy this guy's a
bad guy this guy's a bad guy
so i kind of like the fact that common
sense has started to win a little bit
because long-term bad ideas get exposed
and long-term
great ideas win that's what's happening
here here's the problem though uh
it's one thing to have these people at
least call it out and reference it and
acknowledge it
but how do you get to the next point
where something actually happens because
of it
um they've just given way too much power
to the far
far fringe left they are letting them
get away with anything they want
anything they say is not challenged and
that makes their job ten times more
difficult i think
trump should not run for president i
really because don't you
he's so polarizing and people hate him
so much i don't run for vice president
there's no chance there's i'll give you
three seconds to retract
for the good country no way support
desantis oh by the way no no it's not
trump it's either being what president
either a president or don't run again he
ain't doing no vp stuff because he's
already been out there
that's that'll never happen if you truly
care about the country which he does
no i mean don't you think there's almost
no chance for him to get elected
he brings out the worst out of so many
people in this country so if you enjoyed
this little short segment from the
podcast that we did here's another short
segment to watch or if you want to see
the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]